a lot of people are thinking
sounds maybe misheard
too good to be true
in the same way when you say hey i got a
property
the rent's six nine five you can swap it
and get three grand a month a lot of
people
really
that just doesn't sound quite right
and then guess what bang someone else
comes along and takes it
yes or no
so you know you got it you've got to be
starting to take action right now so i'm
going to get you to exercise in a moment
with your partners the prize is
no better than
cash
all right you're going to get
100 pounds each
okay so you've got 15 minutes
and go
[Music]
[Music]
15
what
all right so
oh so nick wow really okay somebody in
the jeans all right so nick and what's
your name mr wales
jason
all right cool nick and jason found 52
potential
rent to rent so nick tell me about them
where did you look what happened
so we've done different cities before
about the type of guests we'd have so we
did big cities so we started nottingham
then we went more touristy but also
quite uh
work-based so we did edinburgh as well
and glasgow and then you did bournemouth
nice we did a few places all right so
pass the past the mic over um so what
was the biggest lesson you learned from
the from this exercise
i didn't realize how many they were out
there there's loads right how do you
realize there's a lot of leads out there
okay good nick what about yourself what
what did you learn
um it's not just tourists there's a lot
of different people looking for
something to say so yeah so you found 50
now here's what's gonna happen right
imagine guys imagine if you two messaged
every single one of those people that
you found now some people what they do
they come on the service to
accommodation intensive and they go oh i
don't want to message anybody
i need to do due diligence first
but there's no point doing
half an hour's worth of due diligence on
one property to message them just to get
told oh it's gone
so what you want to do is you want a
message imagine if you guys messaged all
52 it might be that 10 of them the
landlord
doesn't even respond
10 of them the landlord responds and
says it's gone 10 of them the landlord
responds and then finds out you won't do
a corporate and says no
10 of them
are rubbish
and 12 of them are really decent and out
of those 12 two of them come off which
will be about 500 pound 1 000 pounds for
each of you per month
from just that little bunch of leads
that you found
you know so
really excited about from you guys and
as i said i did promise that the prize
for the person that booked the most
viewings would get 10 pound each
so
well
what did i say they say 20 pounds each
oh 100 pounds between the two of them
100 pounds each down if i even got that
much in my let me let me see so
we got one two
three
four
five six seven eight nine ten there's
there's 100 so congratulations my
brother congratulations nice job
and then one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten a hundred for you
as well well done man massive congrats
can we give these guys a massive big
hand we're gonna grab a c gonna grab a
shake
and grab a c
all right
so
and listen let me tell you something
the money that they just made okay that
little hundred pounds
imagine that imagine getting that every
single day
every single day from a property that
you do not own
that's what happens when you learn to
find these deals
hi i'm jason i'm from wales and uh my
name is nick and i'm from leicester so
as you can see we've got quite a bit of
money in our hands um what happened was
we were told to find several leads um
live at this event which is crazy so not
only are we learning we're actually
applying the knowledge straight away and
actually getting rewarded for it as well
we're surprised to see how many leads
are out there in a short period of time
that we've had on the short of the
training that we've had brilliant how
many how many leads did you guys find 53
in total 53 leads
were you both able to find leads before
coming to the to the event today no this
is the first time i've done it how about
yourself yeah not like this not like
this normally you're not as motivated
but coming here and being around people
that want the same thing is such a big
motivation well anybody can do it i mean
this is my first day and i've just done
it and yeah sometimes you just need that
time limit just to crack on and go do it
and be around people are doing great
things as well and you'll be fine